exhibition will open next week at the
Grand Canal shops inside the Venetian
and here to tell us all about the
immersive experience we have Daniella
Damonte Daniella thank you so much for
being here thank you so this is really
exciting Las Vegas has become home to so
many immersive experiences and I think
it's just so cool to walk through these
different places and kind of get lost in
time but tell us a little bit when you
walk through the doors what can you
experience at your exhibition so we are
opening the exhibition on next week at
the Grand Canyon shops inside the
Venetian Resort and of course a guests
can expect a Leonardo as a scientist and
as well as an artist so guests can
expect the machines and also we have
original paintings and of course our
Masterpiece that is the self-portraits
Pablo lucana wow and I mean guests can
experience a very cultural immersive
exhibition it sounds really really cool
and amazing and you can kind of spend as
much time as you'd like in there right
and take in everything because there's
so much to look at right yeah sure we
get a lot of models for the machines and
also the original paintings and why do
you think after time and time I mean
Leonardo da Vinci's artwork and his
story and everything has really stood
the test of time what do you think makes
him so special well we do know that he's
a master and through science and artists
and of course he was ahead of his time
so even today we we experience the
drawings and of course
his amazing
um
um it's kind of a work of art and yes
everything right in front of our eyes
Danielle thank you so much for being
here I'm really excited this exhibition
opens December 14th 14th and it will be
here through April so you don't want to
miss it all the information on your
screen for the exhibition again those
are the dates it will be at the Grand
Canal shops inside the Venetian be sure
to check it out